[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime outpour and this is the first
video that we are posting here on the
channel after reaching 100,000
subscribers a big thank you to each and
every one of you who took the time to
watch one of our videos and took the
time to subscribe to anime uproar
without you guys none of this would have
happened literally thank you so much in
this video we will be talking about
Durin's newly revealed backstory and
about his mysterious wish that he wants
to have fulfilled by super Shenron as
you surely remember when he was first
asked to fight for universe 11 in the
tournament of power jiren refused he
basically said that he is happy with
just staying in universe 11 and
protecting it no matter what happens in
the tournament but then when Jaron
learns that the winner of the tournament
can have any wish granted to them using
the super Dragon Balls he suddenly
changes his mind and decides to take
part in the tournament at one point
Belmont says that gern has a wish that
he wants granted so badly that he is
willing to sacrifice his own principles
and an episode 122 when Goku tells Jaron
that he wishes to get stronger jiren
tells goku that what he wishes for lies
beyond strength but what is this wish
that Jaron wants granted so badly a wish
that lies beyond strength in episode 127
of Dragon Ball super we learned a little
bit about Durin's backstory and why he
has dedicated his life to becoming
stronger at one point during the episode
Jaron says that strength is absolute
basically implying that the only way to
survive is to become the strongest you
can't trust others to protect you you
can't hope that you'll get lucky and
nothing bad will happen so you have to
do your best to become stronger because
superior strength is the only thing that
you can rely on but if this is the case
and if Jaron has dedicated his entire
life to becoming stronger then why does
he say that what he wishes for lies
beyond strength
in episode one to seven we finally
learned about Darren's backstory and we
found out that he lost his parents at a
young age when they were murdered by a
mysterious evildoer jiren wasn't strong
enough to stop this evil doer and this
fact continued to haunt him throughout
his life Gian was saved from the
evildoer by a man who became his teacher
and together with other fighters Jian
worked on getting stronger so that he
could take down the mysterious villain
who killed his parents however when they
fought the evildoer again they lost and
many of jaren's allies were killed
including his teacher
Kieran's remaining allies gave up after
that and they refused to keep fighting
which led Jian to stop trusting in
others after that the only thing that
Jaron valued was strength because
strength is absolute and only those who
are strong can bring about justice but
again if jaren's tragic life story
convinced him that the only thing that
matters is strength then why does he say
that what he wishes for lies beyond
strength if he only cares about getting
stronger then why did he refuse to
participate in the tournament of power
at first even though at the tournament
he would face strong opponents and
become stronger himself but once he
heard that the winner could make any
wish using the super Dragon Balls jiren
suddenly changed his mind and decided to
participate I believe that episode one
to seven might have just revealed what
Kieran's true wish is and I think that
Android 17 might have figured out
exactly what jiren wishes for during the
episode 17 tells jiren that he lives
obsessed with the past and that he was
just using the rest of the pride
troopers for his own ends 17 seems to be
implying that if Jaron wins Jaron will
want to make things like they were
before he wants to bury the past Jaron
responds by saying strength is absolute
strength forgives everything even the
past and this part about the past about
jiren being obsessed with the past and
wanting for the past to be forgiven is
the key to understanding his wish Jaron
does not want to become stronger now
because he is all
ready incredibly strong but no matter
how strong he is
he cannot turn back time and save his
parents his teacher and his friends from
the evildoer when the evildoer killed
his loved ones many years ago June was
too weak to stand up to him and no
matter how strong he gets now he can't
turn back time and make everything right
again
Durin's wish goes beyond strength
because he wants to turn back time he
wants to undo the evil that was
committed against his people by wishing
everyone who was killed by the
mysterious evildoer back to life no
matter how strong he is now jiren
thought that he would never be able to
save the people from his past but when
he learned about the super Dragon Balls
he realized that he could use them to
finally make everything right again and
this is why he suddenly changed his mind
and decided to take part in the
tournament now if this is gerron's wish
if he wants to wish back his parents and
others who were killed by that evildoer
we have a big problem as far as the
goals and aims of the other fighters we
know that Vegeta wants to use the super
Dragon Balls to wish back universe 6 and
maybe he will even try to wish back
every universe that was erased during
the tournament of power but despite the
fact that his power is unlimited super
Shenron can only grant one wish
wishing back to life people who were
killed a long time ago as jiren seems to
want to do has to be a completely
separate wish from wishing back
universes that were erased only a few
minutes ago there is no way that I can
see as a right now to reconcile jaren's
wish to bring back people from his past
and the idea of bringing back the erased
universes so if Jaron wins the erased
universes will stay erased and if Vegeta
or Goku win then G R instead friends and
relatives will stay dead
unless Jaron ends up changing his mind
and decides to leave the past behind and
to wish back the erased universes
whoever wins the tournament of power
will have a massive impact on the future
of the entire multiverse one way or the
other and just to add an extra twist
into the mix that anybody else noticed
that our friend Frieza keeps finding
ways to stay in the turn
he gets beat up by topo he gets beat up
by jiren but somehow he always manages
to hang on and not drop out of the
tournament
we know that Frieza has a very different
idea for the super Dragon Balls than the
others if he somehow wins Frieza will
either wish himself back to life
permanently or he will go a step further
and try to make himself the strongest
being in the multiverse instead of Zeno
I wonder if some kind of last-minute
twist with Frieza and the super Dragon
Balls is coming and that is why Frieza
keeps holding on in the tournament all
this time also the big question is who
was the mysterious evildoer that killed
jiren spirits we never see his face we
just see his eyes glowing red and some
sort of purple haze or mist around him
so I wonder is he maybe someone we know
and they are hiding his identity to keep
it a surprise
is he still alive or was he defeated by
jiren once jiren became strong enough
also because this evildoer wasn't shown
with a proper body I couldn't help but
get a sort of infinite sum a sous-vide
from him there has been a theory going
around for quite a while that jiren is
not originally from universe 11 but that
he is actually from one of the six
universes that were erased by Zeno
before the tournament of power even
began this theory is particularly
interesting now that we know that
Jared's family and friends were killed
by a powerful villain what if this
villain was conquering universes and he
managed to conquer and corrupt six
universes before Zeno found out and then
Zeno decided to erase these six
universes to contain the damage just
like future sin all decided to erase the
future timeline in order to contain
infinite samaithu I have been wondering
about those six universes and the real
reason for why they were erased for a
long time so I would love to see this
get addressed at some point during this
arc maybe someone will use the power of
the super Dragon Balls to wish for all
the erased universes to be revived and
then instead of just surviving the
universes that were erased during the
tournament super Shenron decides to
revive every single universe including
the other six that would be a very
interesting development since I am
really curious to see what happened
inside these six universes but let me
know what you guys think am i right that
yearns wishes to turn back time and save
all the people that he was too weak to
save when he was younger do you expect
that Jun will manage to win and fulfill
his wish or do you think that the super
Dragon Balls will be used to wish back
the erased universes let me know down
below and also let me know what you
think about the mysterious evildoer from
Durin's past is he just some random bad
guy or will he turn out to be someone
important in the end if you enjoy the
Dragon Ball super videos on this channel
be sure to leave a like to let me know
and if you are new don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
we are now posting daily anime content
on Twitter and Instagram so feel free to
follow us there at anime uproar before
we end off I'm just going to quickly
address some popular questions from my
previous video where I talked about the
real reason that Goku keeps getting
stronger as predicted I got a lot of
comments on that video saying that Goku
just gets stronger because of plot
because of plot armor and sure Goku does
need to be stronger in order for the
plot to advance that makes sense but
Goku doesn't get stronger just because
someone waves a magic wand or something
along those lines there has to be a
reason for why he keeps getting stronger
and why he stays one step ahead of the
other fighters within the story and my
personal view that I argued in this
video is that Goku's unique personality
is what makes him stand out from
everyone else I will link that video in
the description and also at the end of
this video if you want to see what I'm
actually talking about other popular
comments that I got on that video were
that the reason that Goku gets stronger
is simply saying power or the Zheng Kai
boost but in the Dragon Ball super manga
it is implied by Future Trunks that
Saiyans can use this power to get
stronger up to a certain point but
because Vegeta and Goku have far
surpassed the power of a normal saying
the Zheng Kai boosts no longer increases
their power to a significant degree on
top of that in the video itself I
compared Vegeta with Goku and I talked
about why Goku usually seems to be one
step ahead of a jito as well and of
course we know that Vegeta is a full
blooded Saiyan just like Goku so again
the Zheng Kai
boost itself does not explain Goku's
unique power and that is it for this
video if you're interested in more
Dragon Ball super content we have a full
playlist now I will link it in the
description and at the end of this video
as always thank you so much for watching
thank you again for over 100,000
subscribers it's really unbelievable and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]